In inglorious bastards,
Quintin Tarantino wrote a funny sequence
where a German officer mix up the story
of King Kong with the story of the
American slave trade.
Every question he asks has the same
answer for both of their shifts.
Guys,
I love you.
Thank you.
Yeah,
it's really cut conflict on show
finished.
Listen to you guys,
and
that's what kink concept,
the German officer and to intern
Terentino's clearly think King Kong is
an allegory for the slave trade.
Get the creators of King Kong had
repeatedly denied this interpretation of
the movie saying there are no hidden
meanings.
It's just the story to them.
This disconnect between Creator and
audience brings to light.
One of the most important questions in
film discussion.
Isn't interpretation still valid?
If it's not what the artist intended?
The answer has broad implications for
analyzing art.
If meaning is objective than discussion
becomes much more narrow.
Critics must take the artist's word as
law and only look for meetings that the
artist consciously intended.
On the other hand,
if meaning is subjective,
a critic can find any message they want
in a film,
and that means anybody can throw around
any theory they want.
English teachers can over analyze
curtains,
no matter what the artist says,
so where's the line?
Let's have a look at how artists talk
about and make their movies to figure
out the best mindset towards analyzing
into over analyzing film.
Some directors do clearly state their
intentions for a movie.
In a rare interview from the Cohen
Brothers,
they mentioned that the big Lebowski is
based on the ward detective novels from
the thirties and forties,
but with a humorous twist,
it has the main character in over his
head,
a complicated and morally ambiguous
narrative and an unreliable supporting
cast,
but instead of smoking cigarettes like
most,
no more heroes,
he smokes marijuana.
One of the several humorous twists on
the conventional detective stereotypes
for deeper movie ideas.
Many directors create a movie with an
idea in mind,
but not only will directors hide the
meaning of their movies,
they may even film the movie
deceptively.
In American Psycho Director Mary Heron
had William to folk portray his
character in three different ways.
The first way the character thinks
Patrick Bateman killed Paul Allen.
I just wanted to know if you know
the second he thinks he didn't do it.
People just disappear.
And the third he's unsure to think that
one of his friends killed him for no
reason whatsoever would be too
ridiculous.
Isn't that right?
Patrick here and edited these portrayals
together to have the character
constantly switched.
His opinion of Bateman between takes the
choice,
creates a movie full of uncertainty and
it adds to the frenzied toxic male
dominance within the movie.
Ang Lee's do the exact same technique in
brokeback mountain.
I played it as though I knew what was
going on with Jake's character Jack and
that he had been cheating on me with men
and I knew about the gay bashing and I
also played it as though I had no idea
am I that this is how my husband died
and those takes got merged in the final
film.
So I don't actually know and knows the
truth in his head and it's not important
to me because I think the ambiguity is
what is the strength of that scene and
what's heartbreaking about it.
When filmmakers create a movie with
multiple meanings,
they tend to keep their intent a secret.
Anyone else have a theory about what it
could be?
Use that.
So it's good.
I'm not going to say what it is that's
could.
Oh,
you may not know.
I never talk about themes.
It's a very big shame when something is
finished and then people want you to
translate it back into words.
It never will work.
It never will go back into words and be
what the film is.
It's like describing a piece of music.
You don't hear the music,
you just see the words.
It's better to let people conjure up
their own ideas.
Having seen an experienced the film.
I mean they want you to say,
I think you know,
this is a story of the duality of
duplicity of governments or something
like that.
And you know,
I hear people try to do it.
Sometimes it's usually is a bullshit or
is it work is good.
It's sort of a,
well,
it's usually irrelevant.
Kubrick might be the best director to
look at when discussing over analyzing
because his movies are some of the most
analyzed in American cinema.
The documentary room to 37 focuses
entirely on fan theories about the
shining.
Some of the ideas suggested in the
documentary are pretty ridiculous.
Like when they cleaned,
Kubrick airbrushed his own face into the
clouds as the family drives to the
hotel.
After hearing about his intense shooting
schedules and extremely detailed
production design,
fans have seen to build a mythos around
Kubrick believing he put specific
meaning into every little thing.
Despite all of this sort of a parker
full stories about me,
almost all of which you're unsure.
You don't have unlimited resources and
they do watch the budget and uh,
you know,
you do have to account for what you're
doing.
The stories about cubic largely ignore
how he himself described his shooting
process.
He says he actually doesn't always put a
particular meaning in his directing
choices.
I'm pretty good at generalized
statements,
but when I'm asked what is this,
but I still can't tell somebody what
Gloria is about.
Iceland as much more of an intuitive
process.
More like what I would imagine writing
music is like rather than us sort of
structuring an argument.
This intuitive approach doesn't make
Kubrick's films any less meaningful.
It just means while he's making the
movie,
his intent isn't always immediately
obvious to him.
He instead makes choices that feel right
instead of constantly dealing with
hidden meanings.
I never
deal with subutex when I'm writing,
ever,
ever.
I keep it about the text.
I keep it about the scenario because I
know there's a lot there but I don't
want to.
I don't want to know it right now.
So where does that leave room for
analysis?
In both cases where directors hide the
meeting and where they don't work with a
specific meaning in mind if you can't
know the objective truth,
but that doesn't mean analysis is hope.
Bless the very basic things.
It's especially from Mr. Orange is
coming from,
I'm dying and I want to go to the
hospital,
but just in writing those words,
just all this stuff just started pouring
out and that was when I realized it was
a father son.
Story going on
in this interview,
Tarantino reveals a crucial truth about
filmmaking.
He shows us how he subconsciously put a
deeper meaning in his movie.
It doesn't matter if directors work with
one meaning in mind or work purely on
intuition.
Everybody brings their prior experiences
them in the creative choices they make,
and that doesn't stop at the director.
Every person involved in the process of
filmmaking places their worldview into
the work,
and a good analysis reveals these hidden
meanings.
To me,
it's very obvious.
I mean,
of course King Kong is a metaphor for
the slave trade.
I'm not saying the makers of King Kong
meant it to be that way,
but that's what.
That's the movie that they made,
whether they meant to make it or not.
This analysis works because it fits with
the time period.
The movie was made.
It's not only convincing,
but the analysis also makes the movie
more impactful.
Some interpretation seemed to miss that
analysis should add something meaningful
to the movie.
In this particular interpretation,
King Kong shows how white people have.
The 19 thirties may have feared the free
black population in America.
Not only is that interpretation well
supported,
but it also invites the viewer to think
about the movie in a fresh and
interesting way.
Even if it is true that Kubrick
airbrushed his face into the clouds.
How does that add to the movie?
And strangely enough,
maybe some stories are better enjoyed
without analysis.
Kubrick once said,
if you submit to a completely logical
and detailed analysis of a supernatural
movie,
it will eventually appear absurd.
The true measure of a great supernatural
thriller he says,
isn't in its hidden meanings,
but in if the audience had a good
freight,
believes the film they were watching and
retain some sense of it.
With brokeback mountain,
the true analysis of Jack's death isn't
what matters.
The fact that Ang Lee leaves the
audience uncertain objects.
Fate makes his ending that much more
heartbreaking.
There's no sense of closure for us or
for Ennis.
So maybe the next time you watch the
ending of 2001 a space odyssey,
don't obsess over the details.
Kubrick actually did reveal what he was
going for in that ending
came out because when you
say sound foolish,
whereas if they're dramatize,
I'll link his interpretation in the
description,
but before you click on that,
watch the ending one more time and think
about the emotion it evokes because even
with a particular meaning in mind,
Kubrick built that ending based to not
around his own meaning but around how he
wanted it to make you feel.
So when your teacher over analyzes blue
curtains in a story,
the problem isn't that it's not what the
artist meant.
The problem may be that the teacher got
so caught up in analysis that they
missed what made the book's so great in
the first place.
God,
the big problem with over analyzing film
comes from under researching.
If an analysis is inconsistent with the
rest of the movie or doesn't have a lot
of concrete evidence,
it doesn't hold up well in most areas of
film.
Criticism.
Education is key to coming up with the
best analysis.
When it comes to actual film production,
the same principles apply.
To learn more about filming professional
footage with tools you already own,
you can sign up for the diy filming
class on skillshare.
Skillshare has over 20,000 classes that
covered tons of topics from business to
filmmaking.
The first 500 people to click on the
link in the description below can get
two months of completely free access to
skillshare.
That's the film making class,
plus thousands of others ranging from
creative writing,
marketing,
and design.
Thanks for watching and thanks to
skillshare for sponsoring this video.